partly things that I'm gonna regret
putting this one up but we'll see how it
goes
[Applause]
[Music]
so despite my better judgment I want to
circle back around and talk once again
about the Doctor Who episode Rosa series
11 episode 3 aired this past Sunday and
I want to talk about it for a couple of
reasons well one reason overall and then
I'll basically explain that which is
that I was more or less fine with it
on initial viewing and having now taken
you know a day or so to think on it more
I'm finding I'm having increasing issues
with it and I kind of want to talk about
those and where I'm coming at with this
and we'll see if it makes any sense to
anybody else so before I get into any of
this one thing I want to make as clear
as I possibly can if you liked this
episode if you loved this episode if
this episode was uplifting for you if
you found it touching if it moved you
wonderful that is fantastic and I know
some people had that response I saw it
on Twitter I saw it in my comments
section wonderful the problems that I
have with this episode that I'm going to
be detailing are the problems that I
have with this episode I am NOT trying
to project these out to you nothing that
I talked about here should be
interpreted as therefore because of this
you shouldn't like it know like it love
it get more out of it than I did that's
fantastic I do not wish nor ever seek to
take that away from anybody nobody's
wrong for liking this episode and then
also before I get into it the other
thing I'm gonna mention is I'm gonna
kind of reverse my one well not my one
but one of my more notable criticisms or
at least things that I wasn't so sure
about when I did my original review
which was the villain
he you know he appeared for all intents
and purposes just to be a racist with a
bit of tech and having thought on that
more I actually really like that I like
that you know that no matter where he
comes from whether it's far in the
future no matter what that you know
these problems don't suddenly vanish
just because society as a whole may have
gotten better so I like it for that
reason
I I there was somebody in the comments
was like we don't get an explanation of
his racism and I actually thought about
that and like well we we shouldn't like
that that's a that's a classic mistake
that so many films and shows do which is
to try and explain and quantify racism
as if it's a logical response like oh
he's racist because you know he blames
black people for this specifically but
it people don't I mean to paraphrase
something
Lindsey Ella says people don't logic
themselves racist it's not a logical
response it's something that a lot of
people have to varying degrees but it's
it's an emotional response it's not a
logical one so seeking an explanation as
to why he's racist kind of defeats the
point he is and that's what matters as
far as the story goes so the few issues
that I had with him as a villain I'm
actually gonna take off the table not
even gonna talk about that my issues are
actually kind of something that I was a
bit more praising of originally which is
the actual depiction of Rosa Parks and
of how all that plays out so this I'm
gonna give fair warning right now I
tried very very hard not to get
political on this channel I feel in many
ways this isn't the place for it I don't
like alienating people and
you know that's yeah I was gonna say
this isn't my soapbox
it is insofar as it's my channel I can
talk about what I want but I I didn't
start the channel the intention of it
being that but while I'm gonna try and
keep it up with a pretty narrow focus
this is going to be probably the most
directly politically minded thing that
I'm gonna have put out thus far maybe
because I don't I don't actually
consider my LGBTQ stuff normally to be
especially political in nature it's me
talking about representation but that
this one's gonna get a little bit more
into actual politics and if you don't
want to hear that if you don't if you
either don't care what my politics are
or you have no interest in them cool
check out no hard feelings but that's
your warning from here on out this is my
show so let's start by me explaining the
mindset at which I'm the mindset at
which I'm coming at this from because I
will be very frank and say that that
mindset has a pretty big influence over
what I'm gonna talk about so if you
either didn't already know or what have
you I have a fluid sense of gender that
puts me as part of the lgbtq+ community
generally I've considered myself queer
it is a gender variant so some people
use transgender as you know a specific
very specific term it's meant to be an
umbrella so you can consider that I that
I fall under that as well so the
headspace
that I'm coming at this from is that
earlier in the day on the same day this
episode aired the Trump the the news
broke that the Trump administration is
making moves to in federal guidelines
and for the purposes of federal
enforcement
is seeking to define gender rigidly as
an immutable element which is assigned
at birth and no matter what you do it
does not change which means that if this
happens and there's no reason that it
shouldn't this isn't this isn't
something that gets voted on this
somebody's just planning to do or his
administration is what it means is that
even someone who has gone through years
of hormone therapy even someone who has
had a full surgical sexual reassignment
would still be considered by the federal
government to be the gender that they
were assigned at birth and it's I mean
it's erasure it's it that there was no
other word it is it is literal erasure
of people's identities and you know
people can quibble about what does or
doesn't qualify as you know transgender
and people can argue over people who
have had no hormones and no surgery who
still identify as agender other than you
know they were they were born into and
you know you can have your arguments
over that but this is massive this
sweeping this is not exceptions
basically unless you can prove on a DNA
level that you are something other than
what you were born as which that's rare
they don't care so what does that have
to do with Rosa with this episode with
this story that's being told well I will
tie any more specifically in a little
bit but I want to single out two things
that bothered me on seeing them
initially and it took more time more
thought to figure out why so the first
is there's the conversation between Yaz
and Orion
which actually takes place on the TARDIS
I believe and where you know they talk
about Rosa Parks which she goes through
and it gets that and you know 50 years
later there was a black president and in
that same conversation there is a very
quickly mentioned and then moved on from
Ryan line that Ryan has about getting
stopped more than his mates but the fact
that it then moves on to and then the
America will go and elect a black
president and kind of stops there that's
troubling to me now that's not me saying
that the show should have called out
Trump by name actually I think that
would have been a terrible idea but what
I mean is if you are looking at the
track record for for civil rights and
the push for equality and the measures
being put in place to attempt to
equalize things you know whether it be
by race or anything else but even
certainly specifically with race things
have back slit since you know post
Obama's presidency so you know the the
elements of the Voting Rights Act have
been rolled back there's voter
disenfranchisement issues and you know
things being worked through the course
because of the ways in which voter rolls
are being purged had appeared to be very
targeted and and all these sorts of
things so to say that however many years
later Obama gets elected president and
then to stop there it feeds into the
very worrying perception and narrative
that what we elected black man racism is
over which is ridiculous
but it's I I would it I honestly would
have not sing about this mo knurl if
they hadn't mentioned that you know
Obama's election later on I feel like
mentioning that and then failing to say
but you know the fights aren't like
actively point out but you know the
struggle doesn't end something that that
feels like a cop-out but the thing I
really want to focus on is the scene the
big scene on the bus where the doctor
and her companions have to watch this
happen but they can't step in now I
understand well first of all I
understand a lot of people really like
the scene and again I am NOT trying to
take that away from you and I understand
the thinking behind this behind putting
them there making this as real as
possible for them so there's proper and
appreciation that that these characters
can get for what it was that happened
and what it was that went down but
here's the problem it creates a scenario
that subtext shoot Julie is saying these
downtrodden people have to stand up for
themselves and you have to let them
don't help
and that is not a conscious message of
this episode I do not believe that for
even a second do I think that but I
think it's a case where they didn't
follow through the implications of what
they were doing which is something that
I run into from time to time talking
about lgbtq+ representation because I
said in my previous review that I was
quite impressed that they didn't fall
into the what would have been the
obvious pit of the doctor and the
Companions actively pushing rose the in
some way they get to claim some level of
the accomplishment some level of
responsibility for what Rosa Parks did
either by you know pushing her and
pushing her as a person to ensure that I
mean they they manipulate time and
circumstance to make sure that it
happens but they don't do anything to
her they don't do anything to give her
initial motivation she doesn't get a pep
talk from people from the future you
know they don't give her directly as a
character a nudge none of that because
that would have been that would have
been what I'm about to talk about that
would have been even worse because that
would have been removing her agency the
agency of a real true historical person
who did something significant that
helped move forward some very important
things so that would have been
absolutely the worst thing so they were
right to avoid that but the upshot of
what they've done instead leaves a
situation where the people who aren't
the oppressed don't step in and help
they just watch and they pull for the
team to get there
so the reason I talked about what is
going on with the Trump administration
and definition of gender as being a
rigidly defined thing is because I don't
want to be quietly rooted for from the
sidelines I want to be I want myself in
people who are I and honestly I'm not
even the most directly impacted by this
there are people a people I know a hell
of a lot more potentially directly
impacted by this I want them to have
people actively fighting at their side
standing up next to them saying no this
is not okay
and obviously this show could not
possibly know the context under which I
personally was viewing it they're not
responsible for that but I think and as
I said you know having them get actively
involved in the scene in such a way that
it actually alters the history of the
actual event would have been worse so
what am I actually saying I think what
I'm saying is that Doctor Who as a show
as it currently exists was not equipped
to tell a story like this I think in 48
minutes with the way this this show with
the tools at its disposal I think will
open better not to try and tell this
story and that's not me saying that
certain writers shouldn't write things
I've talked about that before anybody
can write anything and for the
restrictions that they had I think they
did you know about as good a job as
could be done with this kind of my point
for what they were trying to do I do
think the resulting episode is about as
good as it was gonna get but I'm
personally right now
just in a in a place where good enough
isn't good enough so I think that
there's a reason that by and large when
science fiction and fantasy stories
choose to tackle heavier elements like
racism that they generally do it
allegorically they do it through aliens
you know they do it through you know
machines they do it you know through
they do it through something that is
applicable but does not have to be a
one-to-one allegory because when you
tackle it directly it gets so
complicated that and because you're
dealing with real history you don't get
to throw your hands up and go look it's
just a it's just a show just watch well
no you're depicting reality you're
depicting a real moment a real moment
that matters you're acknowledging that
everything about this episode says that
this matters and that the people who
made the show understand that this
matters but they the show is not
equipped to be able to properly give all
the layers and all the nuance and all
the context for this to work and not in
some way undermine some element of it
and because like I said I think for
these sorts of stories adequately works
so much better you know people can say
that they just like dioxygen because of
how on the nose it got with you know
it's anti-capitalism thing fine but
think of how much worse that would have
been if the doctor had basically tried
to tell some bird if doctor who tried to
tell some version of that story in the
middle of the housing crunch or the 1929
stock market crash how much more cringy
would that have been
science fiction can be great and
wonderful for telling these sorts of
allegorical stories but it needs to be
an allegory because you're introducing
fantastical elements into
something that you know this isn't this
isn't Queen Victoria this isn't a long
ago and far away thing this is very
reflective of what is being dealt with
now and I just I don't I don't think the
show was equipped to deal with it and I
think it probably would have been better
if they hadn't so I think I will wrap it
up on that note like I said I I'm sorry
if this got overindulgent like in terms
of just being an outlet for my my
ramblings I mean it often is but usually
it's my geeky ramblings this was um like
I said more political than I usually
like to get but if you have listened all
the way through I appreciate it thank
you if you are or you know anyone who is
affected by what is going on know that
you are loved and you are a valid and
one last final thought don't tell me
that I can't be imposing the political
reality of America into a British show
because it's a British show telling you
a piece of American history that is
relevant to what's going on with
politics right now in America this show
opened this can of worms
I just dumped the worms all over the
table but let's bring it back on a
positive note I'm sad and I'm frustrated
I'm kind of infuriated but I'm also okay
not everybody is so if you know anyone
who needs help and he's reassurance let
them know that you are there for them
because
believe me they really need it right now
they don't need you to stand at the
sidelines and watch and hope they need
you right they're actively supporting
them actively fighting for them so
please do that and if you need that I
hope you haven't so there's the links
and whatever down below that whatever
check them out if you want if you feel
like it
keep comments respectful if you leave
them and whatever your thoughts are drop
it down in the comments and let's talk
about it because you are the council and
I just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]